course contributors to poverty our well
not so good to have a low IQ you know
people don't like the idea of IQ because
it seems so arbitrary you know have a
high IQ well it's not like you deserve
it exactly it's you set up that way
pretty much right from the beginning
it's very very very very stable you can
make a high IQ person stupider why no
not educating them up to the level of
their possibility but taking someone who
has a low IQ and trying to raise that
it's like if you can figure out how to
do that well you know Nobel Prize time
for you because people have tried that a
lot and most recently with those you
know luminol Lumosity games and that
sort of thing and the evidence that
those produce anything other than
brilliant performances on the Lumosity
game itself is basically zero we haven't
been able to figure out how to see
because intelligence is a cross-domain
phenomena and you can get really good in
a single domain by practicing like Matt
and what you want is to practice like
Matt in a single domain and hope that it
generalized to other domains that's the
holy grail of intelligence increase it's
like no no one's done it people claim it
but the claims never hold up and people
have been trying for a long time to do
it and they haven't been able to do it
and differences in IQ to really make a
difference you know I mean you guys
average IQ is probably 125 130 at at 115
Year at the 85th percentile and 115
would barely get you going for you for a
hard university 130 you're probably
graduate school material you know 145
you're up there at the range where you
can probably do pretty much whatever you
want although as you get smarter the
scatter between your abilities increases
so you might have a very high verbal IQ
but not be so good at mathematics or the
other way around but it's a massive
contributor to lifetime success
and I don't know what to do about that I
mean why do smart people make more money
well they get to where the edge of
production is faster so if you have a
thousand people in you rank order than
by IQ the smart people are going to come
up with the new ideas first and they're
going to have more ideas and they're
going to strategize better and you know
what with an IQ of 90 which is 15% of
the population you think about that 15
percent of the population that's pretty
much the threshold for reading
instructions and being able to follow
them so you know and our society is
increasingly sophisticated so it's by no
means obvious you know the Liberals
think well this society is unfair
because there's unemployment and the
Conservatives think well there's a job
for everyone but none of them think well
there are massive massive massive
differences in people's ability far
greater than anyone realizes and that
poses a structural problem